let me show you what the people want all  right this is the starting position  i usually like to play d4 here sometimes  i play c4 and sometimes i play knight to  f3  the thing with knight f3 is that if your  opponent wants to play the grunfeld  then you can use tricky move orders like  g6 e4 to try to get them off the green  field so it has an advantage  against certain move orders of course  you give up a little something to  but i feel that against most opponents  the pros  outweigh the cons now we have transposed  into a line of the pierz ufemsev defense  which is a very reliable opening for  black  but like gives up a little space in the  center and therefore  white often has a promising game with  his full pawn center pawns on e4 and t4